campaign group paid to pollute has
claimed that the uk government has given
nearly 14 billion pounds to oil and gas
companies since the paris agreement was
signed comes just weeks after cop 26
countries including the uk committed
there to phasing down inefficient fuel
subsidies as part of the glasgow climate
pact boris johnson told world leaders
they needed to match action to their
promises on fighting climate change but
is his own government doing
enough uh anna the the paid to pollute
uh report out today is is talking about
well all talk and no action from the
government is that a fair assessment
i think so and i particularly wanted to
draw attention to one element of this um
of this report of this of of the
estimate so um the report says that um
there were uh 3.7 billion pounds issued
as new subsidies for decommissioning of
oil and gas rigs
um and what's happening at the moment is
it's effectively kind of like dumping
that money in the sea it's it the
government is paying oil companies um so
the companies taking responsibility
themselves the government is paying oil
companies to
um remove aging oil rigs and a lot of
the time because of the way that this
policy is set up a lot of the time what
ends up happening is they just end up
getting towed away let's say and left on
a beach in bangladesh to sort of just
sort of sit there and rust or
to be kind of recycled in in a sort of
informal economy with people getting
paid poverty wages or less um so really
um you know that money isn't isn't fit
for purpose that policy isn't fit for
purpose we need something a lot better
than that
boris johnson talks about the uk
building back greener but this is going
to take concerted and coordinated effort
from all sectors
how do we ensure they have the climate
leadership and know what to do in order
to make that happen
well i think it's
it's true that we we know already what
we need to do we need to dramatically
change the way our economy is structured
and we need to change where our our
money is invested and to be quite frank
the government is saying one thing and
doing the complete opposite the actions
it's taking you know investing in new
oil fields or investing in new coal
mines or
subsidizing fossil fuel companies or
expanding airports is completely counter
to what they've promised as the
president of the cop and also after cop
26 and
inca is completely inconsistent with all
of their targets to to meet uh under the
the paris agreement and the glasgow pact
it's completely inconsistent and what
they actually need to be doing is
withdrawing subsidies for fossil fuels
investing in cleaner greener solutions
creating green jobs and accelerating
that transition to a society where we
don't have to rely on these ancient
old technologies that aren't going to
get us anywhere and anna what about on a
more local level cities businesses
making net zero pledges too how do they
turn those into concrete action
so absolutely every uh it's great to see
that lots more businesses are pledging
uh to reach nether emissions by um such
and such days um and same from towns the
same from regions uh but from that you
need to build to an actual plan and um
we've done um our own polling a little
while ago on uh kind of what the uk
workforce thinks of um how the green
transition is being planned and what we
found was yes we all want to see that
transition happening and only one in
four um workers in uk have said that
they've had a chance to feed back to
their employer on their ideas okay what
has to happen i'm really sorry to cut
you off anna and ella we are out of time
thank you very much